I'm Dalibor Šandor.
I come from Serbia, Novi Sad.
I come from the inclusive theatrical
artistic group Per.Art.
I describe my work as
something of a contemporary dancer
but more as a performer.
My name is Xavier Le Roy
and I am an artist
working in the field of choreography
and also, since last year,
I'm a Professor at the Institute
for Applied Theatre Studies in Giessen.
"If you could make a performance,
what should it be called?"
and I said "We Are Not Monsters".
They asked me why and I said it's
because people look at us as some kind of monsters.
In that way, they don't socialize with us,
they are scared of us,
sometimes, they are even disgusted by us,
they don't want to approach us,
they want to remain in their groups,
and the second factor
is that I really, but really, like horror.
Horror literature, horror movies,
horror videogames and things like that.
I liked his proposal.
I'm also interested in this idea of monsters.
I have this sentence about monsters
from Michel Foucault always in my mind,
where he says:
"We are all monsters".
We will see what Dalibor thinks about this.
I know that, in his fantasy,
he is very connected with monsters
in fantastic movies, so it's something
that he is attracted by.
My relationship with monsters
would be more to look to
what is monstrous in each of us
or can we understand something
or can we encounter
voluntarily or involuntarily,
consciously or unconsciously, something
that would be understood as monstrous
in each and every one?
Monsters are interesting to me
because they are different from the others.
Yes. And this is something
you also experience and you want to share.
That's also something I understood from
our week of work.
To share how one can be
seen by the other as different
and that the difference one has
is not necessarily the one
that one want to have as a difference.
We have talked a lot about it this week.
This notion of yes, we are all different
but the problem or the question we have
is when this difference
is making the other a monster.
I think the question is:
Will this difference be acceptable to society?
- Yes.